I should probably explain what a Tanger is to the audience. I go, Oh yeah.
Cause YouTube just recently got one. Right? We got,
we've got a joke gift from a friend of ours who gave us a tango,
which is just a set. It's just a, it's a branded Fleshlight, Fleshlight. No,
a Japanese flesh.
It's a high class flashlights flashlights where I see them make me look
uncomfortable. Like I, sorry. When I see them, I feel uncomfortable.
Like I see it. I'm like, why does it look like that? Why is it?
What's it like donkey Kong is lit. It's disgusting. What is that?
It's so gross. I never heard anyone. Tango's donkey,
stereotypical flashlight. Anyone want to stick their Dick in? Yeah. Yeah.
That's true. You gotta be do that. Yeah, because the thing is,
you know, no one's using like a Fleshlight and own horn.
They actually be looking at it, looking at it to be like, Oh yeah.
I'm like basically a now. You know what I mean?
Like nobody cares what it looks like. I dunno.
I dunno how Tinga managed to make it look normal now they make it look like a,
like a, like an ornament. Yeah. Like a sleek thing.
I don't know if you come to the Japan,
go check it out there and like donkey hotel. Yeah.
So there's like different types of Tenga. There's like,
I remember the first time I heard of it was just tender eggs, which Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Which I have never seen them. It's like, it's like, it's like a,
you can get like a half dozen or like a dozen it's like in the natural,
like egg cotton. So, so, so yeah, it's they,
they sell actual egg cartons and there's these Tanger eggs,
which are actually like, I've never, where's wonderful.
Where do you put your Dick in there?
So you have to like crack it open and then it kind of stretches out.
So it's basically,
it's basically just like way where you literally just crack it open on the side,
kind of just do this and it cracks on the side. And then basically like the,
the, the Fleshlight pot is kind of like squashed in.
So you like stretch it out and then you kind of just wrap it up.
Don't ask me how I know that
I've never understood people look Jack off in a socks. What's up with that?
I don't know anyone who drags off in a song, hear it all the time.
I thought that was just an urban legend. One of my university who did it,
he would Jack off into, he had,
he had socks specifically for Jackie carpet on like that.
Like how was that comfortable?
Some reason the thought of using tissue is too much effort or getting in.
It's like rubbing your bed, Dick on the carpet. It's like,
it just sounds like it hurts. Is that helpful? What has happened is that
you get a taste for the, you can't go back because,
but you hear it all the time. Right? It's like the whole like, Oh,
crusty socks kind of thing. I'm just like, ah, you know, that's a funny,
fictional thing that never happened, guy. My one, he would use them,
like he would use did his dirty socks that he could, you know,
when you go to bed, take off your socks. Right.
I would just throw them in his room. Then when he was going to do it,
he would grab one. And then he was like, well, it doesn't matter.
I'm gonna wash it anyway. I'm like, so you're telling me, you're telling me,
look at the straight, you might've played like rugby. You might've gone running.
You would use that shot. And then he literally gave himself his own foot foot.
He gave himself a self foot job, basically. [inaudible],
I'm so sorry to the listeners who are grossed out by this yet. But yeah,
I just couldn't believe it. And I, I was, I've asked people like, do do this.
This is the thing that you do know anyone they're like, yeah.
I know people who know people who do it. And I'm like,
why are you friends with them? What's wrong with you? Yeah.
But what if they're doing like, uh, Oh yeah. A friend of a friend of mine
that I've heard people who have found out like that brothers or like the sister
found that brother doing it. I've heard that. Oh,
that's the worst that's close was walking in your brother.
You see as like shocked. Yeah. Why are they crushing it? Oh my God.
You don't understand how they cause people I've heard of people as well using
the same sock more than once without cleaning it. Yeah.
Do they want to get like a UTI? That's what,
it's just like the speed run any percent to like a sexual transmitted person.
It's like, I don't understand at any percent,
this is like Victorian era syphilis simulator.
Like what is this at which point was the tissue just too like complicated to
figure out a box. They, they,
they're not hard to put on any surface they're flat, you know, just,
or if you can't even do that, just roll of toilet paper, you know,
like that'll also suffice to understand. I mean like dude, aside from like,
apparently wonky into socks of which w which is what we're talking about now.
Do you actually know anyone who owns like a pocket or like got like a non
Tanger? Yeah. Like a non tango. I feel like people don't admit it. I feel like,
I feel like it's probably way more than I realized.
I don't know anyone who's put like, cause they're not telling you,
is it just, is it just a thing that guys just don't tell each other?
Or is it just a thing that guys just don't buy? I don't know.
I think there's a certain shame in admitting that you come into a plastic toy.
I feel as well. Like maybe we were just hanging out with like,
this is not those kinds of people. You know what I mean?
I think it's also because like you said,
they look ugly and it looked weird. Like there's no,
there's no way that your mom opens a drawer and see, you see,
as it sees like an owner hall or like a pocket puts, you explained that away.
Like, to me in my mind, it has to be like, there's two graphs, right?
There's effort to clean and enjoyment. I get out of it. And I,
so you like midmaxing pocketbooks because the problem is right.
Is that I don't want to clean it.
I don't want anything to do with it when I'm done.
I want it to be done and dusted you get it in a tissue. You throw that away.
Right. It's gone. It's out of my mind. Like,
do I really worst case scenario if I'm really desperate for lube,
for some reason, I'm sure I can just loop up my hand. Right.
But I don't want to make a mess. Um, that is like my priority here.
I just want to get this over with, I'm not trying to have, like,
I'm not lighting candles, you know, accenting the air. Like I don't give a.
I'm just trying to get it done. Turn on the mood light. Like,
I don't understand by who,
like it's enjoyable to them that they're willing to go then to the kitchen,
have the shameful thing and just like, all right, I'm gonna clean out my GEs.
Yeah. I don't want to touch that. I don't want to get,
I don't want to do anything. It,
I could discuss it when I get a little bit on my hand. I'm like, Oh no,
that won't do it. I'll get that off. Some people are just, just don't care, man.
It's just, it's just weird for me. Because like, it seems like it's, you know,
socially acceptable for girls to have like whatever sex, the way they want.
Right. And I mean, you go to, I mean, they sell it on high street stores.
Like in England, we have an summers where you can just go in there and I get it.
It's for a guy it's like, you can do it in like two seconds. Right.
Get it done if you really need to. Right. Yeah. For good.
I guess that takes longer. Right? It's bit harder.
You actually have to like wipe the canvas and turn on the mood lights, right?
Yeah. But I also imagine like fingering yourself is probably, I don't,
I wouldn't know. I bet it's probably a little more difficult. I,
to know that the farm is way harder than the pinky. NA
[inaudible] have you done? What fingered myself? Yeah.
No.
What the did you think of yourself? Something you want to tell us?
[inaudible] have you ever
[
inaudible] Jerry, like my stool broke one time and never been the same.